Nous avons lu du verset 1 au verset 10 le chapitre 5 d'Ézéchiel,
mais nous allons surtout nous concentrer aujourd'hui sur les versets 5 au verset 7 à 8.
Et pour rapidement résumer, Ézéchiel était un sacrificateur,
donc ce qui se passe c'est qu'il va être déporté,
la première fois que Nebuchadnezzar attaque le royaume de Juda,
il va déporter une partie du peuple, notamment les élites.
Et Ézéchiel était un sacrificateur qui va être déporté.
Et lorsqu'il se retrouve à Babylone, il est à Babylone,
il est découragé parce que, il est étonné,
parce que c'est même la première fois que là ils sont en train de vivre ce genre de choses.
Jusqu'à présent Dieu les avait épargnés à un certain niveau,
et même Jérusalem n'avait pas été autant attaquée.
Mais là Jérusalem a été détruite,
et ils étaient assez découragés parce que ça allait à l'encontre pour eux,
ça allait à l'encontre de ce que Dieu révélait.
Mais là Dieu va se révéler à Ézéchiel pendant qu'Ézéchiel est à Babylone,
et il va lui donner une mission,
c'est-à-dire qu'il lui dit à un moment qu'il l'établit comme une sorte de sentinelle
pour délivrer un message au peuple.
Parce que ce qui se passait dans le cœur des croyants,
enfin des croyants, des juifs qui avaient été déportés à Babylone,
c'est qu'ils étaient sûrs qu'ils allaient rentrer,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils étaient sûrs que Dieu allait faire quelque chose,
et qu'ils allaient revenir à Jérusalem.
Mais Ézéchiel a un discours contraire,
il est en train de leur dire non,
le fait que vous soyez même en train d'espérer repartir à Jérusalem
sans vous rendre compte que ce sont vos péchés qui vous ont conduit là,
vous êtes en train de faire une erreur.
Donc Ézéchiel, Dieu est en train d'utiliser Ézéchiel,
il a utilisé aussi d'autres prophètes pendant ce temps
pour faire comprendre au peuple que s'ils avaient été déportés,
c'était à cause de leur péché,
et qu'ils allaient devoir rester pendant un certain moment
à Babylone.
Et d'ailleurs Jérémie va même écrire une lettre,
à un moment Jérémie enverra un courrier
pour faire comprendre aux frères là-bas aussi
qu'il leur fallait envisager de rester à long terme à Babylone.
Et à partir du chapitre 4,
nous avons vu un moment que Dieu va manifester
par plusieurs sortes de signes.
Donc il demande à Ézéchiel d'aller parler au peuple,
mais ça ne suffira pas,
ce que Dieu montre c'est que ça ne suffira pas
pour qu'il comprenne.
Donc par plusieurs signes,
Dieu va demander à Ézéchiel de manifester plusieurs signes,
donc à un moment il va lui demander de s'agenouiller,
pas s'agenouiller, mais se coucher sur un côté,
il va lui demander à un moment de faire une représentation
de Jérusalem,
avec quelques éléments,
une poêle et des choses.
Donc il va représenter Jérusalem,
il va représenter le jugement
qui tombe sur Jérusalem,
et il va devoir se coucher pendant un certain nombre de jours
sur un côté ou sur un autre.
tout cela pour pouvoir signifier ce que Dieu était,
le jugement que Dieu était en train d'accomplir.
Et lorsque nous avons débuté le chapitre 5,
Dieu continuait dans ce sens.
Qu'est-ce que Dieu demande maintenant à Ézéchiel?
Il lui demande de prendre un instrument tranchant,
donc un rasoir,
et il lui demande de se raser les cheveux,
de se raser la barbe.
Et ensuite, il lui demande de prendre une balance pour péser.
Et c'était une prophétie,
parce que ce que nous réalisons,
c'est que tout ce que Dieu va donner en détail,
comme instruction à Ézéchiel,
c'est exactement tout ce qui s'accomplira plus tard,
lorsqu'il y aura le siège de Jérusalem.
Donc à un moment, il lui dit
de péser ses cheveux,
de les partager,
et il lui demande de brûler un tiers dans le feu.
Donc la dernière fois que nous avons vu,
il lui demandait de brûler un tiers dans le feu
au milieu de la ville,
lorsque les jours du siège seront accomplis.
Donc là, il parlait de tous ceux qui allaient mourir,
que ce soit par le feu, par l'épée.
Ensuite, il lui dit,
prends un tiers et frappez avec le rasoir tout autour de la ville.
Donc même ceux qui allaient essayer de fuir,
ils n'allaient pas pouvoir fuir,
parce qu'ils allaient être frappés aussi.
Et il dit,
disperse-en un tiers au vent,
et je tirerai l'épée derrière eux.
Et c'est tout ce qui s'accomplit.
Il y a certains qui ont réussi à fuir,
ils se sont même réfugiés dans d'autres nations,
en Égypte notamment,
mais même là, le jugement de Dieu les a poursuivis.
C'est-à-dire, Dieu leur a dit que même quand vous allez fuir
dans les nations où vous fuirez,
à cause de la colère de Dieu,
à cause du fait que le jugement de Dieu tombe sur vous,
Dieu vous poursuivra même,
même dans les nations où vous allez fuir.
Donc même ceux qui avaient fui en Égypte,
finalement, Nebuchadnezzar est descendu aussi en Égypte
pour aller les chercher.
Et donc c'est ce que nous avions vu
la dernière fois.
Et là, dans la partie que nous allons aborder aujourd'hui,
du verset 5 au verset 7,
c'est une partie qui nous parle,
Dieu donne une explication,
et c'est important,
parce que le problème que les Juifs avaient eu à un moment,
le peuple de Dieu avait eu,
c'est que le devoir de mémoire qu'ils avaient,
ils l'avaient perdu.
Donc à un moment,
quand tous ces événements sont en train d'arriver,
pour certains, ils trouvaient que Dieu était injuste.
Quand ces choses sont en train de se passer,
ils ne comprenaient pas pourquoi Dieu était en train de punir Jérusalem.
Ils ne comprenaient pas pourquoi,
si Dieu disait avoir choisi Jérusalem,
pourquoi il se permettait d'accomplir ces jugements.
Et voilà une première partie d'explication
que Dieu va donner au travers d'Ézéchiel,
donc quand il lui demande de se raser,
de raser la barbe,
de raser les cheveux,
normalement c'était une, on va dire,
une sorte de honte pour un sacrificateur,
de devoir tout se raser.
Mais Dieu demanda à Ézéchiel de le faire,
afin qu'Ézéchiel envoie un message au peuple,
pour qu'il comprenne,
parce qu'il ne comprenait pas en quoi ils étaient coupables.
Mais là, en utilisant Ézéchiel,
Dieu voulait illustrer pourquoi ils étaient coupables.
Donc, dans la partie que nous verrons aujourd'hui,
nous voyons un moment que Dieu n'a pas soudainement décidé
de punir Jérusalem.
La punition, le jugement qui arrive,
découle de plusieurs siècles d'accumulation.
La patience de Dieu a été sur eux pendant plusieurs siècles,
et pendant plusieurs siècles,
ils n'ont fait qu'accumuler des offenses,
ils ne se sont pas repentis comme ils le devaient,
jusqu'à ce qu'arrive ce moment.
Quand nous lisons la Bible,
c'est toujours habituel dans la Bible
de pouvoir donner le nom de la chose qui est signifiée par le signe.
Donc là, quand Dieu demande à Ézéchiel de se raser la tête,
il va aussi expliquer en quoi consiste,
quel est le signe,
que signifie cette tête.
Et dans le cas de la tête rasée,
ça représentait Jérusalem.
Ce que Dieu était en train de dire,
c'est que Jérusalem,
qui pouvait être fière
de ses ornements,
qui était fière de ce qu'elle était,
allait être dépouillée.
Jérusalem allait être vidée de ses habitants,
elle allait être mise à nu,
et donc elle allait être rasée.
Je reprends l'expression,
il y a une expression dans Ésaïe qui dit à un moment,
il a pris un rasoir à louage,
c'est-à-dire,
quand Ésaïe parle des Assyriens,
il va dire à un moment que Dieu a pris les Assyriens
comme un rasoir de location
pour pouvoir raser.
Et donc Dieu,
cette fois-ci,
ce n'était pas les Assyriens,
mais Dieu utilise les Babyloniens
pour pouvoir apporter le jugement.
Donc, la tête rasée d'Ézéchiel
était en train de signifier le fait
que le jugement allait arriver sur Jérusalem.
Jérusalem allait être vidée de ses habitants,
la nation allait être vidée,
et à la fin,
qu'est-ce qui allait rester dans la nation ?
Ça allait être les plus pauvres,
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment,
ils ont déporté toute la population,
et il n'y a que pratiquement
les plus pauvres du pays qui sont restés,
et qu'ils ont décidé de laisser dans le pays.
Donc, la tête d'Ézéchiel,
qui était un prêtre,
qui était un sacrificateur,
était le meilleur symbole
pour représenter la chute
de la ville de Jérusalem.
Et ce que nous ressortons,
ce que nous voyons là-dedans,
et c'est intéressant parce que
l'Évangile nous a enseignés
au travers de ces choses.
Nous voyons que Dieu,
la patience de Dieu,
et c'est vrai que même pour moi,
à un moment, le contexte,
on n'arrive pas souvent
à réaliser le contexte,
mais quand nous étudions le texte,
nous voyons à un moment que
toutes ces choses arrivent
à cause des choses
qui ont été prononcées
lorsque Moïse donne le Deutéronome,
le livre de Deutéronome,
le livre de Lévitique.
Là-dedans, il y a des paroles
sur lesquelles Israël s'engage
en disant,
« Au moment,
ils vont honorer le Seigneur,
et s'ils n'honorent pas le Seigneur,
les jugements qui sont décrits
dans Deutéronome
et dans Lévitique
leur arriveront. »
Donc, nous voyons que
il est très important pour nous
de ne pas toujours nous fixer
sur l'instant présent.
Lorsque nous voyons
ce que Dieu est en train de faire,
il y avait déjà eu
plusieurs siècles de patience
que Dieu avait fait
vis-à-vis d'Israël
avant que ce jugement n'arrive.
Donc, ce n'était pas
un jugement qui arrivait par hasard.
Et pour nous,
aussi en tant que corps de Christ,
ce que Paul nous dira plus tard,
c'est que ces choses,
ces événements,
nous sont arrivés
afin de nous servir de leçon.
Ce sont aussi des avertissements
pour nous en tant qu'Église,
corps de Christ,
de comprendre aussi
que ce qui est arrivé aux Juifs
est une leçon aussi pour nous.
Et donc, aujourd'hui,
nous allons voir,
d'abord, quand Dieu parle
des privilèges
qui étaient accordés de Jérusalem,
nous allons voir
en quoi consistaient
les privilèges
qui étaient accordés à Jérusalem.
Et par la suite,
nous verrons aussi
quelle est la culpabilité
de Jérusalem.
Donc, c'est une première partie
de voir aussi
pourquoi Dieu condamne Jérusalem.
Donc, c'est le premier point
au verset 5
sur les privilèges
accordés à Jérusalem.
Ainsi parle le Seigneur
à l'Éternel.
C'est là,
cette Jérusalem,
c'est très important,
c'est là,
cette Jérusalem
que j'avais placée
au milieu des nations
et des pays d'alentour.
Donc, ce que nous voyons déjà,
quand vous étudiez l'histoire,
la période
dont nous sommes en train
de parler
est une période charnière
pour les historiens
parce qu'elle permet
de comprendre le monde.
c'est-à-dire,
l'essentiel
de ce que nous connaissons
du monde,
de l'histoire du monde
à ce moment,
c'est de passer
dans cette région.
C'est-à-dire,
cette région
qui va du Moyen-Orient
jusqu'à à peu près
l'Irak,
le bassin de l'Irak.
C'est là où on va avoir
concentré l'histoire
et la plupart
des premiers grands empires
dans l'Empire syrien,
les empires babyloniens,
perses,
toutes ces choses-là.
Donc,
nous voyons un moment
que Dieu n'avait pas placé
Jérusalem
dans un coin obscur
du monde.
Dieu a placé Jérusalem
au cœur même
de ce que le monde
était en train de vivre.
Dieu ne l'a pas placé
loin des voisins.
Jérusalem était,
quelque part,
à une place
qui était très importante,
même stratégiquement
pour plusieurs nations.
Mais Dieu l'a placé
au milieu du royaume
qui était peuplé.
Dieu l'a placé
au milieu des royaumes
qui étaient,
pour la plupart,
à l'époque,
les plus civilisés
de l'époque.
Dieu l'a placé
au milieu des royaumes
d'où sont venus
l'apprentissage,
d'où sont venues
la lecture,
l'écriture plutôt,
d'où sont venues
l'écriture,
les arts,
les sciences,
une contribution
des sciences,
toutes ces régions-là,
là où Dieu a placé
Jérusalem,
Jérusalem était
au centre de ces choses.
Et donc,
Dieu a placé
Jérusalem
à une partie
de l'histoire,
une partie du monde
où l'histoire
du monde s'est accomplie.
Et dans certains cas,
elle était même
le carrefour
pour certains commerces.
Si vous lisez même
la Bible,
quand vous allez lire
l'histoire de Salomon,
vous allez voir un moment
comment Salomon
profitait pour faire du commerce,
pour ramener des chevaux,
parce qu'il y avait,
c'était, voilà,
un carrefour
pour plusieurs nations
qui passaient par là.
Donc,
les privilèges
que Dieu
avait faits,
lorsque Dieu
permet que Jérusalem
ne soit pas isolée
ainsi,
c'est que Dieu,
et ça,
ce n'était pas
une compréhension
pour les nations,
nous ne pouvons le comprendre
que du point de vue
de Dieu,
c'est que Dieu
avait choisi Jérusalem.
Dieu avait jugé
Jérusalem digne
et il avait préféré
parmi toutes les nations.
Parmi toutes ces grandes nations
dont nous sommes en train
de parler,
il y a,
alors,
c'est vrai que pour nous,
croyants,
quand on parle
du royaume de Juda,
de Jérusalem,
on le voit toujours,
mais en fait,
quand vous regardez
au point de vue de l'histoire,
c'était un petit royaume.
Ça n'a jamais eu
la portée d'un royaume
comme d'un empire
comme Babylone
ou autre,
jamais.
Mais Dieu
va dire à un moment
qu'il a choisi cette nation.
Il a choisi cette nation
au détriment
des nations voisines
et de leur ville.
Et d'ailleurs,
le psaume 68,
verset 16,
la parole de Dieu
nous dit à un moment
« Pourquoi montagne
aussi nombreuse
avez-vous de l'envie
contre la montagne
que Dieu a voulu
pour résidence ? »
Dieu dit à un moment
qu'il a choisi
d'être au milieu
de cette petite nation.
Le premier privilège
qu'ils avaient,
c'était d'avoir été
choisi par Dieu.
C'était une ville
et d'ailleurs,
ce qui va aussi
toucher des personnes
comme Ézéchiel,
c'est que tout au long
de l'histoire,
c'est là où nous voyons
que ce jugement
était dur pour eux,
c'est que tout au long
de l'histoire,
nous parlons,
la plupart des petits royaumes
comme Israël,
c'était des royaumes
qui avaient toujours
fini par être englobés
par d'autres nations
plus puissantes.
mais il était impossible,
si ce n'est grâce
à la main de Dieu,
il était impossible
qu'un petit royaume
comme le royaume
d'Israël puisse perdurer
pendant autant de siècles
sans avoir été envahi
par une nation majeure.
Et ça,
Israël était donc
conscient à un moment
qu'il y avait des nations
qui appréciaient
ce qu'Israël
pouvait leur apporter.
Donc,
il y avait quelques nations
avec qui ils étaient
en bon terme.
Mais il y a d'autres nations
aussi qui avaient
toujours eu cette ambition
de pouvoir envahir Jérusalem.
Et si vous lisez même,
vous allez lire
lorsque Ézéchias,
par exemple,
était roi,
l'Empire Assyrien,
qui était alors
l'Empire le plus puissant
de l'époque,
les Assyriens ont essayé
de prendre le royaume
de Juda.
Le royaume de Juda,
ils n'ont pas réussi
à le prendre.
Et donc,
Israël le savait
depuis des siècles
que Dieu les avait choisis,
que Dieu veillait sur eux.
Le deuxième privilège
que Dieu leur avait donné,
c'est qu'ils avaient été créés
pour avoir une bonne influence
sur les nations voisines.
C'est-à-dire que
quand Dieu choisit
de faire de ce royaume
sa résidence,
de faire de cette ville,
donc quand je parle
de Jérusalem,
c'est symbolique,
mais ça veut parler
de tout le royaume
de Juda,
c'est tout l'ensemble.
Donc,
Dieu va dire au moment
qu'il les avait placés,
c'est le passage
au verset 5 qui dit,
ainsi parle l'Éternel,
c'est cette Jérusalem
que j'avais placée
au milieu des nations,
au milieu des nations.
Donc,
Dieu les place,
vous voyez un peu
comme si vous étiez
dans une maison.
Si vous êtes dans une maison
et que vous avez besoin
d'éclairer une maison
à un moment,
vous n'allez pas
allumer la bougie
dans le coin
le plus reculé
de la maison,
sinon vous n'allez pas
voir le reste.
Vous allez placer la lumière
à peu près au centre
pour qu'elle puisse
éclairer tout le reste.
Et c'est dans ce sens
que Dieu est en train
de parler de Jérusalem
qui était là
pour pouvoir répandre
la lumière de Dieu.
la révélation divine de Dieu
pour leur montrer
que la bénédiction
dont elle bénéficiait
était à cause du Dieu
qu'elle servait.
Donc,
Dieu l'avait placée
au milieu des nations
afin que toutes les nations
autour d'elle
puissent recevoir
la bénédiction de Dieu
et que même cette bénédiction
puisse par la suite
s'étendre
jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre.
Donc,
Dieu était là
pour éclairer
et l'exemple même
que nous avons,
c'est Deutéronome 4,
verset 6,
va nous dire un moment
lorsque Dieu leur donne
cette loi,
qu'est-ce qu'il leur dit
dans Deutéronome ?
Il leur dit,
vous,
donc il parle
des commandements de Dieu,
vous les observerez
et vous les mettrez en pratique
car ce sera là
votre sagesse
et votre intelligence
aux yeux des peuples
qui entendront parler
de toutes ces lois
et qui diront
cette grande nation
est un peuple
absolument sage
et intelligent.
Ce que Dieu fait,
c'est même déjà
de poser des bases,
c'est-à-dire
la bénédiction d'Israël
n'allait pas venir
de sa puissance militaire,
de quelque chose
dont il pourrait
s'enorgueillir.
La gloire d'Israël
allait venir
du fait que leur Dieu
les avait bénis
pour qu'ils soient
une nation intelligente
et sage
et certaines nations
ont eu l'occasion
de pouvoir l'observer
et même quand nous lisons
dans le livre des rois,
nous voyons au moment
que plusieurs nations,
plusieurs rois,
plusieurs émissaires
ont quitté leur nation
pour venir entendre
la sagesse de Salomon
parce qu'à un moment,
ce que Dieu était
en train de faire
et là, dans ce sens,
Israël était en train
de remplir son mandat,
le mandat que Dieu
lui avait donné
d'être une lumière
au milieu des nations
lors des premières années
du règne de Salomon,
nous allons voir
un moment que ce mandat
est rempli.
Même lorsque David est roi,
nous constatons
un moment que plusieurs nations
venaient aussi
pour admirer
ce que David pouvait faire
mais encore plus,
ça s'est encore plus
accentué avec Salomon
et donc ces nations
venaient parce que
elles constataient
qu'au milieu
de cette nation,
il y a une sagesse
qu'elle pouvait avoir
et nous voyons
que l'histoire,
le Seigneur nous l'a montré
dans l'histoire,
on a eu l'exemple
de plusieurs nations
comme ça,
par exemple,
à un moment,
on va parler d'Athènes.
Athènes était réputée
pour ses philosophes,
les gens venaient
pour pouvoir écouter
les philosophes
pour connaître la sagesse
humaine qui s'en dégageait.
Et donc là,
Dieu avait décidé
qu'au contraire
d'une sagesse humaine,
Jérusalem devait pouvoir
délivrer la sagesse
divine de Dieu.
Mais,
malheureusement,
quand on parle
de ces privilèges,
ils n'ont pas réalisé
la grâce
qu'ils avaient eue
d'avoir ces privilèges,
ils n'ont pas réalisé
la bénédiction continuelle
qu'ils auraient dû être
pour toutes les nations.
et le problème,
c'est que leur cœur
ont penché
vers ce sur quoi
Dieu les avait avertis.
Toujours dans ce livre
de Deuteronome,
et je prends
les livres de Deuteronome
pour vous montrer
un moment que lorsque
le jugement de Dieu arrive,
ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'anodin
qui arrive comme ça.
C'est quelque chose
où la patience de Dieu
s'est exercée,
mais la parole de Dieu
était claire aussi.
Lorsque Israël
prend cet engagement
en disant,
au moment,
nous nous engageons
à obéir à la loi
de l'Éternel
et si nous ne le faisons pas,
toute cette malédiction
retombera sur nous.
Dieu dit,
Deuteronome 8,
verset 11 à 14,
voilà la mise en garde
de Dieu vis-à-vis d'Israël.
Garde-toi d'oublier
l'Éternel, ton Dieu,
au point de ne pas observer
ses commandements,
ses ordonnances
et ses lois
que je te prescris aujourd'hui.
Lorsque tu mangeras
et te rassasiras,
lorsque tu bâtiras
et habiteras de belles maisons,
lorsque tu verras multiplier
ton gros
et ton menu bétail,
s'augmenter ton argent
et ton or
et s'accroître
tout ce qui est à toi,
prends garde
que ton cœur
ne s'enfle
et que tu n'oublies
l'Éternel,
ton Dieu,
qui t'a fait sortir
du pays d'Égypte,
de la maison de servitude.
Voilà le problème
qu'Israël a eu.
Israël a oublié
l'Éternel.
Le devoir de mémoire
qu'Israël aurait dû avoir
de génération en génération
pour rappeler
ce que Dieu
avait été pour eux,
à un moment,
ce devoir de mémoire
s'est brisé.
À un moment,
il y a eu une génération,
il y a eu des générations
qui n'ont pas
fait ce devoir de mémoire.
Ils ont oublié
l'Éternel,
ils ont oublié
les commandements
de Dieu
et ils ont commencé
à se glorifier,
c'est-à-dire
leur rapport à la loi
a totalement changé.
Quand Dieu donne
la loi à Israël,
il leur donne la loi
pour qu'ils comprennent
un moment
qu'ils ont besoin de lui.
Il leur donne la loi
pour qu'ils comprennent
l'importance
des sacrifices
qu'ils sont en train de faire
en attendant
l'arrivée de Christ.
Il leur donne la loi
pour comprendre
un moment
que sans lui,
ils ne pourront pas
trouver la paix.
Mais ce que Israël
va faire,
c'est d'ajouter des choses,
c'est-à-dire,
ils vont trouver
cette loi trop dure,
ils vont violer
le commandement de Dieu
en ajoutant des choses,
en retranchant des choses.
Et finalement,
ce qu'ils vont faire
là-dessus,
c'est que leur cœur
va s'enfler
en se disant
au moment que du moment
qu'ils ont établi
leur propre justice,
ils peuvent suivre
leur propre pouvoir.
Et voilà ce qui a précipité
le jugement de Dieu.
Bien sûr,
par la grâce de Dieu,
nous voyons au moment
que Dieu n'est pas resté
sur cet échec.
La pleine bénédiction
qu'Israël aurait dû accomplir,
nous avons pu l'accomplir,
Dieu a pu l'accomplir
avec l'arrivée de Christ,
l'établissement de l'Église.
Et c'est la même mission
qu'Israël avait eue
de pouvoir rayonner
pour apporter
la lumière de Dieu
aux nations.
C'est cette même mission
qui a été donnée à l'Église,
de pouvoir prêcher
l'Évangile à toutes les nations.
Donc,
d'apporter cette lumière
à toutes les nations.
Qu'est-ce que nous apprenons
au travers de la parole
par rapport à ce problème
au niveau des privilèges ?
Nous apprenons aussi
que ce n'est pas différent.
Ce que je suis en train de dire
quand je parle même
de cette continuité
du mandat
qu'Israël avait eue
et que nous sommes en train de faire,
Paul va nous dire un moment,
vous au contraire,
et vous voyez,
il y a des similitudes
avec Israël,
vous au contraire,
vous êtes une race élue.
Un sacerdoce royal,
une nation sainte,
un peuple acquis,
afin que vous annonciez
les vertus de celui
qui vous a appelé
des ténèbres
à son admirable lumière.
Vous qui autrefois
n'étiez pas un peuple
et qui maintenant
êtes le peuple de Dieu,
vous qui n'aviez pas
obtenu miséricorde
et qui maintenant
avez obtenu miséricorde.
Nous aussi,
ce que Dieu nous montre
aussi là-dessus,
c'est de prendre conscience.
Israël n'a peut-être pas
pris conscience
des privilèges
que Dieu lui donnait,
mais pour nous,
la leçon,
c'est de prendre conscience
des privilèges
que Dieu nous a donnés.
Nous sommes une race élue,
ça veut dire un moment
que si aujourd'hui
tu es présent,
ce n'est pas un choix
personnel que tu as fait,
c'est la grâce de Dieu
qui s'est exercée
pour que tu sois élu
et que tu sois présent.
Dieu t'a établi
pour faire partie
du sacerdoce royal,
Dieu t'a établi
pour être parmi
une nation sainte,
un peuple qui s'est acquis.
Et quel est le but ?
C'est que nous annoncions
les vertus
de celui qui nous a appelés
des ténèbres
à son admirable lumière.
C'est dommage aujourd'hui
que nous arrivions
dans des églises
un moment
et que la préoccupation
des personnes dans l'église
soit juste de prêcher
sur comment quelqu'un
va obtenir sa voiture,
de prêcher pour bénir les gens
pour qu'ils aient
plus de biens terrestres.
Mais la vérité
que nous devons comprendre
un moment,
c'est que si nous avons
été sauvés,
c'est pour que nous puissions
annoncer les vertus
de celui qui nous a appelés
des ténèbres
à son admirable lumière.
Si nous avons été sauvés,
c'est que nous prenions
conscience un moment
que nous qui n'étions
pas un peuple,
nous sommes maintenant
devenus le peuple de Dieu.
Et nous avons un privilège
que le monde ne voit pas,
que le monde ne comprend pas,
mais nous avons eu
le privilège
d'obtenir miséricorde
à cause du sang de Christ.
Et qu'est-ce que cela implique ?
C'est de prendre conscience,
et c'est intéressant aussi
de voir en cette période
de JO
où le monde
est en train de,
par exemple pour la France,
on est en train
de mettre Paris en lumière,
de mettre toutes ces choses,
mais toutes ces lumières
sont vaines,
toutes ces lumières
sont artificielles.
Quand les JO seront finies,
beaucoup de personnes
qui peuvent trouver
une satisfaction
temporaire
repartiront
dans leurs soucis.
Mais la vérité
que nous avons,
c'est que nous,
nous devons comprendre
que nous sommes
une lumière continuelle.
nous sommes la lumière
de ce monde.
Et comme Dieu
n'avait pas permis,
c'est-à-dire que
quand Dieu place
Jérusalem sur une colline,
le but qu'il voulait,
le message qu'il envoie,
c'est de faire comprendre
que Jérusalem
n'était pas cachée,
Jérusalem était visible.
Et nous aussi,
nous sommes comme une ville
qui est située
sur une montagne.
Nous ne sommes pas cachés,
nous sommes visibles.
Nous sommes là
pour éclairer
ceux qui sont autour de nous.
Nous sommes là
afin que notre lumière
puisse luire devant les hommes.
quelles que soient
les circonstances de vie
que nous traversons,
il faut que notre lumière
puisse luire devant les hommes.
Il faut que les hommes
puissent voir nos bonnes œuvres
et qu'ils puissent glorifier
notre Père
qui est dans les cieux.
C'est ça,
c'est ça le privilège
que nous avons
d'être bénis
et d'être appelés
à travailler avec Dieu
à cela.
C'est le privilège
qu'Israël avait
et qu'ils n'ont pas compris
parce qu'à un moment,
leur rapport à la loi
était faussé.
Dès l'instant
où ils n'ont pas compris
à un moment
que Dieu était le Dieu
de leur salut
mais qu'ils ont cherché
à établir leur propre justice,
ils ont perdu
ces privilèges.
Et ça nous permet aussi
de rentrer sur le deuxième point.
Après le point des privilèges,
nous allons rentrer
sur ce point
de la culpabilité
de Jérusalem.
Donc cette culpabilité,
lorsque nous lisons
Deutéronome,
quand nous avons lu
Deutéronome 8,
nous voyons à un moment
que cette culpabilité
venait du fait
qu'ils ont décidé
d'ignorer les commandements
de Dieu.
Et dès qu'ils ont décidé
d'ignorer les commandements
de Dieu,
Jérusalem s'est rendue coupable.
Et là,
Dieu est en train
de faire une accusation.
Vous voyez,
donc à un moment,
certaines personnes
pouvaient être en train
de voir les signes
qu'Ézéchiel était en train
de faire,
de se raser
et de vouloir signifier
que Jérusalem
va être détruite.
Ils peuvent se dire
à un moment,
mais pourquoi si Dieu
aime Jérusalem,
pourquoi il se permet
de faire cela ?
Pourquoi manque-t-il d'amour ?
Mais nous voyons
à un moment que
quand nous lisons
les versets 6 à 7,
on peut dire
que c'est un peu
comme une plaidoirie,
c'est-à-dire que là,
Dieu est en train
de poser les bases
d'une accusation
très sérieuse.
Il est en train de dire
vous voudriez peut-être
me contredire,
mais voilà les points
qui vont faire
au moment que cela
soit arrivé
et qui vont faire
au moment que Jérusalem
n'aura aucune excuse
à trouver
ou aucun même motif
pour trouver que Dieu
est injuste
dans ce qu'il est en train
de faire.
Ce premier point,
premier point de culpabilité,
nous le voyons
au verset 6,
au verset 7 et 6,
parce que vous n'avez pas
suivi mes ordonnances
et pratiqué mes lois,
ça c'est le verset 7,
et verset 6,
les habitants de Jérusalem
avaient refusé les lois
et les ordonnances
de Dieu à multiples reprises.
Donc ça c'est le verset 6,
elle a violé mes lois
et mes ordonnances
et s'est rendue plus coupable
que les nations
et les pays d'alentour,
car elle a méprisé mes lois
et n'a pas suivi mes ordonnances.
quand Dieu établit
l'alliance
avec Israël
au sortir de l'Égypte,
il leur donne ce devoir
de pouvoir garder
ses commandements.
Il leur donne
le devoir
de garder ses commandements
et certains
de ses commandements
leur permettaient
d'être admirés
de leurs voisins
et d'autres
les amenaient
à être méprisés
de leurs voisins.
Mais ce que Dieu voulait,
c'est que ses commandements
devaient être mis en avant
et que les nations
comprennent à un moment
que si Israël est béni,
c'est parce qu'ils obéissent
aux commandements
de l'Éternel.
Chaque fois,
Dieu va toujours
mettre en avant
ce fait
qu'Israël ne doit
jamais se glorifier,
ne doit jamais prendre
pour acquis un moment
que ce serait peut-être
par leur force.
Et d'ailleurs,
voyez un moment
quand Dieu va même
parler pour le roi,
il faut que le roi
n'ait pas un grand nombre
de chevaux
ou beaucoup d'autres choses.
Qu'à un moment,
ils puissent toujours
montrer leur dépendance
à Dieu.
Et donc,
certains voisins
pouvaient trouver cela
ridicule,
mais Israël avait besoin
de mettre en avant
que c'était les lois
et les commandements
de Dieu
qui respectaient,
qui leur apportaient
la bénédiction.
Mais le souci
qu'ils ont eu à un moment,
ils ont rejeté
ces lois
et ces commandements
et leur désir
a été plutôt
de se conformer
aux lois
des nations
alentours.
Et un des plus grands
péchés qu'ils vont
même commettre,
bien sûr,
Dieu va transformer
cela après,
mais c'était même
le fait de demander
à un roi,
lorsqu'ils vont demander
à Samuel
d'avoir un roi.
Quelle était l'indication
pour laquelle
ils voulaient un roi ?
Est-ce que c'était
quelqu'un qui serait
un peu plus proche
pour traiter leurs problèmes ?
Non,
c'était parce que
les nations
alentours
avaient un roi.
Et donc,
la première culpabilité
de Jérusalem,
c'est qu'ils ont méprisé
la parole de Dieu.
Et le fait d'avoir
méprisé la parole de Dieu,
ils ont ouvert la porte
à toutes sortes
d'iniquités.
Et quand ils ont ouvert
la porte à toutes sortes
d'iniquités,
c'est aussi important
pour nous
pour nous de comprendre
à un moment
certaines choses.
Israël
ne réalise pas.
C'est-à-dire que
quand à un moment
Dieu leur donne
ses commandements,
il y avait une bénédiction
qui venait avec
des commandements directs
qui étaient donnés.
Donc,
on les voit avec la table
les dix commandements.
Mais il y avait aussi
des commandements
qui étaient établis
comme un respect
des lois naturelles.
Donc,
vous voyez,
par exemple,
Dieu va leur dire
à un moment
que si vous êtes en guerre,
il ne faut pas
qu'il y ait d'impurité
dans votre camp.
Il faut que votre camp
soit propre.
Pourquoi?
Parce que si votre camp
n'est pas propre,
vous pouvez ramasser
une maladie.
Donc,
il y avait des lois naturelles
que Dieu donnait à Israël
qu'Israël devait respecter
et qui allait montrer
à un moment
la faveur,
la bénédiction de Dieu.
Mais l'homme mépris
de la parole
a fait un moment
qu'ils ont ouvert des portes
à certaines conséquences
de péché
dont ils ont souffert.
Et c'est drôle,
par exemple,
quand je parle
de ces bénédictions,
à un moment,
il y avait la peste.
Je me souviens,
je me souviens,
je n'étais pas là.
Quand il y a eu
la peste au Moyen-Âge,
à un moment,
c'était des rats
qui étaient venus
d'Asie et autres
qui ont été importés
et qui ont apporté
la peste en Europe
et la peste a tué
à peu près
deux tiers de la nation
à l'époque,
deux tiers
des Européens.
la peste s'est répandue
sur toutes les nations.
Et pendant que
la peste était en train
de se répandre
sur toutes les nations,
il y avait certains
qui essayaient de voir
comment ils pouvaient
résoudre le problème,
arrêter ces choses.
Et ils avaient
constaté à un moment
que la peste
ne se répandait pas
au milieu des Juifs.
Donc,
les communautés juives
n'étaient pas touchées
par la peste.
Et quand ils sont
donc allés voir,
en étudiant
les communautés juives,
ils ont remarqué
que l'observation
des lois
de Deutéronome
leur avait permis
d'éviter la peste
au milieu d'eux.
Parce que,
du fait qu'ils respectaient
ce que Dieu ordonnait
comme propriété même
au milieu du camp
et toutes ces choses,
ça avait permis.
Et c'est à partir
de là même
qu'ils ont commencé
dans les solutions
pour vaincre la peste
à un moment,
ils ont commencé
à travailler un peu plus
pour la propriété.
C'est là où on a
commencé à créer
des premiers canaux,
beaucoup de choses.
Et nous voyons donc,
on a un petit aperçu
des bénédictions
que Dieu donnait
à Israël
pour être une bénédiction
aux nations.
Mais ils ont été
dans le mépris
de ces choses,
ils n'ont pas réalisé.
Ils n'ont pas réalisé
un moment que Dieu
les instruisait
pour leur bien.
Ils n'ont pas réalisé
un moment que la voie
dans laquelle Dieu
les conduisait
était une voie
pour qu'ils puissent
trouver leur bonheur.
Et Israël avait échoué,
comme je vous l'ai dit
au début,
Israël avait échoué
dans son devoir
de mémoire.
À un moment,
les commandements
de Dieu
qui auraient dû
être transmis fidèlement
de génération
en génération
de l'empahité.
Et d'ailleurs,
c'est Martin Lloyd-Jones,
je lisais cette semaine,
je vais paraphraser,
ce ne sera pas complet,
mais il disait à un moment
que lorsque les chrétiens
regardent le monde,
si un chrétien est surpris
de ce qui se passe
dans le monde,
c'est qu'il y a un problème.
Les premières personnes
qui ne seront jamais surpris
de comment ce monde
est en train de fonctionner,
de pourquoi ce monde
va mal,
ce seront les chrétiens.
Parce qu'à un moment,
quand nous lisons
la parole de Dieu,
nous comprenons
pourquoi toutes ces choses
arrivent.
Il n'y a aucune chose
qui va nous surprendre,
parce que nous savons
à un moment que notre Dieu
est vrai dans tout
ce qu'il a dit.
Ce sont des choses
qu'il avait annoncées.
Et nous,
en tant que parents chrétiens,
nous avons aussi ce devoir
d'enseigner à nos enfants
l'histoire du monde
selon Dieu.
On peut enseigner
l'histoire du monde,
bien sûr,
à un moment,
on va aider nos enfants
dans leurs devoirs
d'histoire,
géographie,
mais il est important
qu'ils puissent comprendre
à un moment
que la primauté
de compréhension
de ce monde
sera toujours la Bible
au-dessus
de la compréhension
de l'histoire humaine,
au-dessus de la façon
dont l'homme comprend l'histoire.
Il faut leur expliquer
comment Dieu comprend
l'histoire.
Et si nos enfants comprennent,
si nous expliquons
à nos enfants
l'histoire du monde
selon Dieu,
ils ne seront pas surpris
et ils comprendront
même mieux l'Évangile.
Le problème qu'Israël
avait eu à un moment,
et c'est pour ça que
souvent je suis assez étonné
quand je peux discuter
avec des personnes,
quelqu'un va dire
à un moment,
je n'ai jamais lu
l'Ancien Testament,
bien même là je suis en train
de parler d'Ézéchiel,
certains pourront dire
je n'ai jamais lu Ézéchiel
parce qu'ils ont trouvé
que c'était un livre
très dur
et ils sont assez sensibles
donc ils préfèrent
des choses plus joyeuses
comme dans les Évangiles.
Mais quand nous sommes
en train de faire ça,
si tu es dans une situation
où même après plusieurs années
dans la foi,
tu n'as jamais lu entièrement
tous les livres de la Bible,
ce sera aussi difficile
pour toi,
tu seras dans la même situation
que les Hébreux
lorsque le jugement
arrive sur Jérusalem,
tu ne comprendras pas,
tu ne vas pas comprendre
le monde,
le plan parfait
de l'Évangile,
du besoin de Christ.
On peut le comprendre
un moment,
même là quand nous lisons
Ézéchiel,
nous voyons un moment
que comme je vous ai dit,
c'est la mauvaise compréhension
de la loi
et lorsqu'ils avaient été
dans une bonne compréhension
de la loi,
ils auraient compris
l'importance du Messie.
Mais le fait
de mal comprendre la loi,
les Aména ne pas
comprend le besoin
que Christ arrive.
Et si nous,
par exemple,
nous nous abstenons
de lire l'Ancien Testament,
on ne comprendra pas aussi
le besoin que Christ arrive,
pourquoi nous avons le besoin
de ne pas établir
notre propre justice
pour trouver
les faveurs de Dieu.
C'était le problème d'Israël.
Israël avait échoué
et à cause de ça,
ils avaient ignoré
les commandements de Dieu
et à un moment,
ça avait été un problème.
Donc ça,
c'était le premier point
de culpabilité
qu'ils avaient,
c'était le fait
à un moment
d'avoir ignoré
les commandements de Dieu.
Le deuxième point
de culpabilité,
ce n'était pas,
non seulement,
ils avaient ignoré
le commandement de Dieu,
mais ce qu'ils ont voulu faire,
une grande preuve
de leur profanation,
c'est que,
non seulement,
ils avaient ignoré
ces commandements,
mais ils ont violé
les lois de Dieu.
Ils les ont pervertis,
ils en ont abusé
et la Bible nous dit
même à un moment
que Jérusalem
s'est rendue plus coupable
que les nations
et les pays alentours.
Deutéronome 4, verset 1
« Maintenant Israël »
verset 1 à 2
« Maintenant Israël,
écoute les lois
et les ordonnances
que je vous enseigne.
Mettez-les en pratique
afin que vous viviez
et que vous entriez
en possession du pays
que vous donne l'Éternel,
le Dieu de vos pères.
Vous n'ajouterez rien
à ce que je vous prescris
et vous n'en retrancherez rien,
mais vous observerez
les commandements
de l'Éternel
et de votre Dieu
tels que je vous les prescris. »
Israël a choisi
d'ignorer les commandements
de Dieu,
mais ils ont quand même
choisi d'abuser
des commandements de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ont trouvé
un moment
que ces commandements
ne leur suffisaient pas,
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
les accomplir,
mais ils ont choisi
de les déformer.
Et donc,
ils ont rajouté
aux commandements de Dieu
des coutumes
et des usages païens
qu'ils voyaient
des nations alentours
et ils ont rajouté ça
dans les commandements de Dieu.
Ils ont apporté
des dieux étrangers,
ils ont rajouté
des dieux étrangers
aux commandements de Dieu.
Et en cela,
comme nous le dit la parole,
ils ont changé
la vérité de Dieu
en un mensonge.
Eux qui devaient
être une lumière,
eux qui devaient apporter
la preuve du Dieu vivant,
du Dieu unique et vivant,
se sont détournés
de ce Dieu unique et vivant
et ils en ont fait
un Dieu de honte.
Ils en ont fait
quelque chose
de déformé,
d'abusé.
Et pour ça,
Dieu nous dit à un moment
que c'était une des causes
du jugement.
Jérusalem,
elle a violé mes lois
et mes ordonnances.
Le fait qu'ils aient
rajouté des choses
à la parole de Dieu,
qu'ils aient retranché
d'autres choses
pour essayer de trouver
une paix superficielle,
avait fait à un moment
que c'était une preuve
de culpabilité.
Le jugement tombait aussi
à cause de ça.
Et là encore,
dès que nous qui sommes croyants,
quand Paul parle des saints,
même quand il parle
de l'église de Corinthe,
une église qui avait
beaucoup de problèmes,
qu'est-ce qu'il dit à un moment?
Il écrit aux saints.
Il est en train de dire
à un moment que
dès que tu es sauvé,
dès que la grâce de Dieu
est dans ta vie,
la parole te considère
comme étant spirituellement saint.
Tu es une nouvelle créature.
Les choses anciennes
sont passées,
toutes choses
sont devenues nouvelles.
Mais si nous,
qui sommes spirituellement saints,
nous décidions de vivre
comme des personnes malades,
alors nous sommes en train
de faire la même chose
qu'Israël a fait.
Israël a rajouté
des choses à la parole,
a retranché des choses
pour essayer de trouver
sa propre justice.
Parce que la justice de Dieu
établie ne leur convenait pas.
Alors ils ont décidé
d'établir leur propre justice,
ils ont décidé d'ignorer
certains commandements
et d'autres commandements
qui les arrangeaient,
ils ont déformés
pour que ça convienne
à leur façon de voir.
Et quand vous lisez même
la suite d'Ézéchiel,
quand Dieu rentre
dans les détails,
il va même montrer
un moment dans le temple même,
un moment dans le temple,
même les anciens d'Israël,
ils avaient permis
de dessiner des figures
de Dieu dans le temple.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils auraient
pu construire d'autres temples,
faire d'autres choses.
Non, ils sont allés jusqu'à
souiller le sanctiaire de Dieu
en y introduisant
d'autres dieux.
Et là, Dieu dit à un moment,
le jugement est irrévocable.
Et donc, pour nous,
si à un moment,
nous qui devons être saints,
nous qui devons être
un exemple
autour de nous
pour la génération
dans laquelle Dieu
nous a placés,
si nous décidons
de vivre comme
des personnes malades,
nous mettons un affront
inimaginable à Dieu.
Nous sommes en train
de donner,
du moment où nous sommes
en train d'ajouter
des choses à la parole
de Dieu,
nous sommes en train
de retrancher des choses,
de donner l'image
d'un Dieu
qui est un tyran.
Parce que les voies
de Dieu sont parfaites,
ses commandements
sont justes.
Et lorsque nous les pratiquons
dans leur justice,
nous sommes en bénédiction
aux personnes
autour de nous.
Mais lorsque nous ajoutons
quelque chose
ou que nous retranchons
quelque chose,
nous sommes en train
de donner l'image
d'un Dieu injuste.
Nous sommes en train
de fausser l'image
que les gens devraient
avoir de Dieu.
Et pour certains,
les jugements saints
de Dieu vont maintenant
paraître iniques.
Imaginez un couple chrétien
qui devrait donner
un témoignage,
donc qui va à un moment
évangéliser ses voisins
et qui pour la moindre dispute
qu'ils auront à un moment,
il y a un qui va balancer
tous les disques de vinyle
de l'autre de la fenêtre,
il va prendre les vêtements,
il va les jeter
parce que là,
il était fâché,
il ou elle est fâché,
donc il prend les affaires
de l'autre,
il les jette.
Repensons même voisins
qui sont en train
de voir cela.
Et c'est toujours intéressant
de 1 Corinthien 3,
c'est Paul qui parle
au Corinthien un moment.
Pour moi, frère,
ce n'est pas comme
à des hommes spirituels
que j'ai pu vous parler,
mais comme à des hommes
charnels,
comme à des enfants Christ.
Je vous ai donné du lait,
non de la nourriture solide,
car vous ne pouviez pas
la supporter
et vous ne le pouvez pas
même à présent
parce que vous êtes
encore charnels.
Le problème,
quand Paul est en train
de mettre ça en exergue
en parlant d'être charnel,
c'était dans le même sens
qu'Israël avait fait.
C'est-à-dire que dès qu'à un moment,
nous décidons
dans certaines parties
de notre vie
d'ignorer la parole de Dieu
parce qu'elle ne nous convient pas.
Lorsque nous décidons
dans certaines parties
d'ajouter des choses
à la parole
parce que ça ne nous convient
pas à être qu'elle est
ou d'en retrancher
parce que ça ne nous convient
pas comme elle est,
nous sommes en train
de repartir
dans une attitude charnelle.
Et ce qui en découlera,
ce ne sont pas des fruits
qui glorifient le Seigneur,
ce sont des fruits
qui nous conduisent encore
au péché,
ce sont des fruits
qui rendent un mauvais témoignage.
Il est impossible
d'être fidèle
dans la lecture de la parole
et de ne pas comprendre
l'importance du pardon.
Mais plus on va s'éloigner
de la parole
et plus on considérera
qu'on peut tout à fait
justifier le fait
de ne pas pardonner
à des personnes
qui nous ont offensées.
Et ça va un peu
dans le même sens
pour la troisième culpabilité
dont Dieu parle.
Il dit,
« Elle a violé mes lois
et mes ordonnances
et s'est rendue plus coupable
que les nations
et les pays d'alentour
car elle a méprisé mes lois
et n'a pas suivi mes ordonnances. »
Donc,
c'est aussi dans ce même sens,
c'est-à-dire,
par rapport à ce qu'elle aurait dû être,
du fait déjà de la lumière
dont Jérusalem avait été éclairée
où elle aurait dû donner
un bon exemple,
il faut déjà savoir
que Dieu,
c'était alors exceptionnel
pour l'époque
parce que toutes les nations
alentour,
c'était des nations
qui avaient plusieurs dieux.
Ils avaient l'habitude
de plusieurs dieux
et là,
on tombe sur un peuple
qui n'a qu'un seul dieu.
On tombe sur un peuple
qui a un dieu
qui demande un culte exclusif
mais le problème d'Israël,
c'est qu'à un moment,
c'est qu'ils ont multiplié
les idoles
et les faux cultes.
Ils ont même encore plus
corrompu la religion
que les païens avaient fait
en corrompant
la religion naturelle.
Vous voyez,
parce que quand les païens
qui décident,
dès qu'ils voient
un éclair,
ils y voient un dieu,
dès qu'ils voient
l'eau qui bouge
dans un marais,
ils y voient un dieu
et les païens avaient perverti
les lois naturelles de Dieu,
les choses naturelles
où à un moment,
ils se sont inventés
une multitude de dieux.
Mais la parole nous montre
à un moment
que pour l'Israël
qui avait déjà pu goûter
à la vérité,
qui avait même goûté
à la délivrance
que Dieu leur avait accordée,
le fait de s'éloigner
des commandements de Dieu
faisait même que leurs conditions
soient pires
que ce qu'ils étaient avant.
La parole de Jitim,
un moment,
ils se sont rendus
plus coupables
que les nations,
c'est-à-dire,
ils sont tombés
encore plus bas
que ces nations
qui étaient dans l'offense.
Et quand on parle de ça,
c'est très grave
parce que les nations
dont nous parlons
sont des nations
qui avaient même l'habitude
de sacrifice humain.
Ce sont des nations
qui sacrifiaient leurs enfants.
et Dieu est en train
de dire,
un moment,
que vous,
Israël,
par le fait
que vous avez ignoré
mes commandements,
que vous avez perverti
mes lois
pour en faire
ce que vous voulez,
établir votre propre justice,
vous êtes arrivés
à un niveau
encore plus bas
que ces nations.
Et encore,
ce qui est étonnant,
verset 7,
il va même encore
leur dire quelque chose.
La quatrième,
la quatrième culpabilité
que Dieu expose,
quatrième point de culpabilité,
il va leur dire un moment.
Voilà.
C'est pourquoi
ainsi parle le Seigneur
l'Éternel,
parce que vous avez été
plus rebelles
que les nations
qui vous entourent,
parce que vous n'avez pas
suivi mes ordonnances,
pratiqué mes lois,
et que vous n'avez pas
agi selon les lois
des nations
qui vous entourent.
Parce que vous n'avez pas
agi selon les lois
des nations
qui vous entourent.
Et Jérémie,
qui vit à la même époque
qu'Ézéchiel,
parce que Jérémie,
c'est contemporain
d'Ézéchiel,
Jérémie dira même,
est-ce qu'il y a une nation
qui change ces dieux?
C'est-à-dire que même
dans l'emphase
qu'Israël est en train
d'apporter,
que les prophètes apportent,
ils vont dire à un moment,
est-ce qu'il y a une nation
qui change ces dieux?
Même quand nous constatons
que les dieux
de ces nations
ne sont pas des dieux.
Et il dit à un moment,
mon peuple a changé
sa gloire
contre ce qui n'est
d'aucun secours.
Malgré la lumière
et la sagesse
des Écritures,
Israël a choisi
de tomber plus bas.
Au lieu d'apporter
la réforme à ses peuples,
de pouvoir apporter
la vérité à ses peuples,
Israël est tombé
plus bas.
Et une chose
qui est incompréhensible
selon les choses naturelles
que Dieu a établies,
c'est que je vous ai parlé
de ce petit royaume
qui a résisté
à plusieurs grands royaumes.
Et lorsque vous voyez
la bénédiction de l'Éternel
sur vous pendant
plusieurs siècles,
comment vous choisissez ?
Et d'ailleurs,
il y a même un épisode,
là je n'ai plus le nom du roi,
mais c'est assez troublant
où à un moment,
il y a un des rois d'Israël
ou de Juda
qui va gagner une bataille.
Même après avoir gagné
la bataille,
il décide
de prendre les dieux
de la nation
qui l'a vaincue.
Et normalement,
spirituellement,
la compréhension
qu'il y avait à l'époque,
c'est que si tu gagnais
une bataille,
c'est que le dieu
qui régnait sur ta nation
t'avait donné la victoire.
Et c'était incompréhensible
de voir qu'aucune nation
n'aurait fait ça.
C'est-à-dire que
dès qu'une nation
t'a vaincu,
pour eux,
c'est la preuve
que leur dieu
t'a donné la victoire.
Donc,
ils ne vont pas se mettre
à adorer
le dieu d'une nation faible
parce que ce dieu
est lui-même faible.
Il n'a pas su protéger
cette nation.
Et nous lisons même
ce discours du roi d'Assyrie
lorsqu'il va menacer
Ézéchia.
C'est ce qu'il va dire
à un moment.
Les dieux des nations
que j'ai conquis
n'ont pas pu
m'empêcher de les prendre.
Mais nous voyons même
qu'Israël a fait
des choses insensées.
Ils ont même choisi
un moment,
il y a même certains,
même après avoir
gagné les batailles,
ils ont choisi
de servir des dieux faibles
qui n'ont pas su protéger
leur nation.
Et enfin,
un dernier point
de culpabilité,
et on va même dire
que c'est,
on va dire
un péché capital
qui va précipiter
le jugement de Jérusalem
et qui va nous être
rappelé pendant plusieurs
fois dans Ézéchiel.
Il se trouve
au verset 11,
parce qu'on l'a un peu
aussi abordé,
mais le verset 11
va nous dire un moment,
c'est pourquoi je suis vivant,
dit le Seigneur,
l'Éternel,
parce que tu as souillé
mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles
et toutes tes abominations,
moi aussi je retirerai
mon oeil
et mon oeil sera
sans pitié,
moi aussi je n'aurai
point de miséricorde.
Le problème,
un moment,
c'est que
ils ne s'étaient pas
seulement contentés
d'adorer de fausses idoles,
mais ils avaient introduit
ces fausses idoles
dans le temple de Dieu.
Et à ce moment,
Dieu s'est retiré
du sanctuaire.
Dieu a retiré
sa présence
du sanctuaire
et Israël
n'a plus que constaté
les dégâts
de cela.
Une chose,
bien sûr,
lorsque nous rentrerons
dans le chapitre 6,
nous aurons l'occasion
de rentrer un peu plus
en détail sur les souillures
dont Dieu est en train
de parler,
mais j'en ai un peu
parlé aussi en disant
de ces exemples
de Dieu,
qu'ils ont pris
de Dieu étranger,
qu'ils ont introduit
dans le temple.
Et nous nous rappelons
à un moment
que notre Dieu
ne partage sa gloire
avec aucun autre Dieu.
Bien sûr,
je parle des dieux
avec un petit dé.
Et là encore,
un privilège
qu'Israël avait
et qu'ils n'ont pas compris
et qui,
pour nous,
doit être important.
Vous voyez,
vendredi,
on a eu à méditer
sur le psaume 103
pendant l'étude biblique.
On a prié là-dessus
et on rappelait
l'importance
de rendre grâce.
Et le problème
d'Israël,
à un moment,
vous voyez,
c'est assez confus
un moment que tu constates
la bénédiction de Dieu,
mais que tu sois
en train d'envier
des nations
qui sont sous malédiction.
Et c'est ce que
Israël était en train de faire.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils n'arrivaient
pas à se contenter,
ils n'arrivaient pas
à apprécier
ce que Dieu leur avait donné.
Ils étaient en train
d'envier
les nations
qui étaient sous la malédiction.
Et à cause de cette envie,
à un moment,
ils ont ouvert des portes
à ce que les idoles
de ces nations
soient
jusque dans leur temple.
Nous devons apprendre
à être reconnaissants.
Quand nous parlons
d'être la lumière du monde,
nous devons apprendre
à être une lumière.
Nous devons apprendre
à être capables
de rendre grâce à Dieu,
à être heureux
de ce que notre Dieu
nous donne.
Nous devons apprendre
à être joyeux
des privilèges
que notre Dieu
nous a donnés,
à ne pas envier
un monde
qui est en train
de partir à la perdition.
C'est un monde
qui est,
on appelle ça,
il y a le terme
en français,
autodestruction.
Souvent,
quand je regarde un peu,
on va parler d'écologie,
de toutes ces choses,
le problème,
c'est le cœur de l'homme.
C'est juste que l'homme
est porté vers le péché.
Et ce même homme
qui veut sauver la terre,
c'est ce même homme
qui veut vivre
dans un péché abondant.
Et le problème,
à un moment,
c'est qu'il est dans une phase
d'autodestruction.
comment nous pourrions
être en train
d'admirer des personnes
qui sont dans une phase
d'autodestruction.
Et souvent,
certains soucis
que nous avons,
c'est que nous
plaçons,
c'est-à-dire,
nous envisageons
une différence de vie
en imaginant,
en étant croyants.
C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment,
nous n'arrivons pas
à réaliser
qu'avant d'être sauvés,
quelle est la vie
que nous menions
avant que Dieu
ne nous visite.
C'était une vie
dont nous ne pouvons
pas nous glorifier.
Mais à un moment,
nous envisageons
que cette vie
serait meilleure
si nous avions
ce que ces personnes ont.
Mais non,
pas la paix.
Et le problème
d'Israël à un moment,
c'est qu'Israël,
malgré la sagesse,
la lumière des Écritures,
Israël n'a pas pu
comprendre
les privilèges
que Dieu lui donnait.
Il n'a pas pu
comprendre
la bénédiction
qu'il devait apporter
plutôt que d'être
en train
d'envier ces nations.
Nous allons,
on poursuivra,
on continuera
la suite des versets
sur le dimanche prochain,
Dieu voulant
pour la suite.
Mais,
une conclusion
qui doit nous faire réfléchir,
c'est de voir un moment
et c'est cette vérité centrale
de voir comment
Dieu a aimé Israël.
Les jugements
qui sont en train
d'arriver
lorsque Ézéchiel
est en train
de se raser
et de montrer
tous ses signes
sont des jugements
qui nous parlent
de siècles
de patience de Dieu
qui nous parlent
de quelque chose
qui avait déjà été établi,
c'est-à-dire que Dieu
aurait pu les juger avant,
Dieu aurait pu détruire
Jérusalem avant,
mais Dieu a été patient,
Dieu a été patient
envers Jérusalem
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
à un point
de non-retour.
Dieu avait choisi Israël
pour afficher ses lois,
ses vertus,
ses jugements,
mais ils ont négligé cela,
ils ont perverti
leur rapport
à la loi de Dieu.
Quand Dieu leur donne
la loi
et même lorsque Dieu
va par exemple
instituer la Pâque,
c'était pour une compréhension
à un moment
que leur salut
ne pouvait venir
que de Dieu.
D'ailleurs,
lorsque la Pâque
est établie,
on se souvient à un moment
qu'aucun d'entre eux,
lorsque l'ange destructeur
passe,
personne ne pouvait
sauver sa vie
s'il n'y avait pas eu
le sang sous les linteaux,
sous les bords des portes,
personne n'aurait pu
sauver sa vie.
Et cette leçon
que Dieu leur donnait déjà,
c'était de comprendre
à un moment
que ça ne pourrait
jamais être
par leur propre justice,
par leur propre compréhension
de la parole de Dieu
qui pourrait
parvenir au salut,
qui pourrait même
garder la faveur de Dieu,
même trouver la paix.
Mais Israël
ne l'a pas compris.
À cause
des bénédictions
de Dieu,
ils se sont vus
supérieurs
à toutes les nations.
C'est ça aussi
qui est assez drôle.
Et même jusque,
lorsque nous lisons
le début du Nouveau Testament,
nous constatons
que c'est un état d'esprit
qui est resté.
À un moment,
Israël va réaliser
qu'ils ont reçu
les oracles de Dieu.
Ils ont réalisé
un moment
qu'ils sont une nation
qui a été bénie de Dieu.
Mais au lieu
de voir cela
dans un sens d'humilité
pour comprendre
qu'étant bénis,
ils sont aussi appelés
à être en bénédiction
aux autres,
ils se sont plutôt
enorgueillis,
ils se sont vus
comme supérieurs
à toutes les nations.
Ils se sont vus
sur un plan moral
supérieur à toutes les nations.
Ils se sont vus,
ils étaient contents
des bénédictions de Dieu,
mais ils voulaient toujours
continuer à suivre
les mauvais penchants
de leur cœur.
Ils voulaient continuer
à pratiquer
la même idolâtrie.
Et voilà même pourquoi
dans certains exemples
de Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
lorsqu'il parle des pharisiens,
de tous ceux
qui vont s'opposer à lui,
il va leur dire
un moment,
c'est ce que vos pères
ont fait
avec les prophètes avant.
Parce que c'était
cette même continuité,
ce même état d'esprit
qui est en train
de se poursuivre.
Et ce qui est drôle,
c'est que dès qu'ils subissaient
les conséquences
de leurs péchés,
sur certaines occasions,
ils se sont repentis.
Lorsqu'ils avaient aussi
des rois qui suivaient
les voies de Dieu,
ils se sont repentis.
Ils sont revenus à Dieu.
Mais dans certains cas,
on va même voir
qu'ils voulaient obtenir
le pardon de Dieu
en voulant tromper Dieu.
C'est-à-dire que
dès qu'ils subissent
les conséquences
de leurs péchés,
c'est parce que
l'arche de l'éternel
n'était pas là.
On va aller chercher
l'arche de l'éternel
et là,
la faveur de Dieu
va nous revenir.
Donc vous voyez
qu'ils étaient conscients
de ce que Dieu
pouvait représenter pour eux,
mais qu'ils avaient
délibérément choisi
d'aller selon les penchants
de leur cœur.
Et Paul nous met en garde,
je vais finir avec ce texte,
ce texte où Paul nous met
en garde
contre ce genre d'attitude
à ce que nous puissions
connaître la loi de Dieu,
vouloir bénéficier
de ses bénédictions,
mais sans la vie
de sanctification
qui va avec.
C'était le piège d'Israël.
C'est à un moment,
ils ont bénéficié
des bénédictions de Dieu.
Ils étaient contents
de connaître la loi de Dieu.
Ils se sont même
enorgueillis
vis-à-vis des autres nations.
mais ils n'ont pas voulu
associer la vie
de sanctification
qui allait avec.
Voilà ce que Paul
nous dit dans Romains 2,
17 à 23.
« Toi,
qui te donnes
le nom du juif,
qui te repose
sur la loi,
qui te glorifie de Dieu. »
C'est un avertissement pour nous.
Après tout ce que j'ai dit,
c'est que nous gardions
nos cœurs,
que nous réalisions
un moment
que nous ne devons pas
prendre pour acquis
les privilèges
que Dieu nous donne.
Et la plus grande bénédiction
que quelqu'un peut avoir,
c'est la présence de Dieu
dans sa vie.
Ce ne sera pas
des bénédictions terrestres.
Et du moment
où Dieu s'était retiré
du sanctuaire,
Israël n'a pas compris
que c'était là
la plus grande perte
qu'ils avaient.
Mais Paul va prendre
cet exemple
et c'est des personnes
qui pourraient être
comme Israël.
« Toi qui te donnes
le nom du juif,
qui te repose
sur la loi,
qui te glorifie de Dieu,
qui connaît sa volonté,
qui apprécie
la différence des choses
étant instruit par la loi,
toi qui te flatte
d'être le conducteur
des aveugles,
la lumière de ceux
qui sont dans les ténèbres,
le docteur des insensés,
le maître des ignorants,
parce que tu as
dans la loi
la règle de la science
et de la vérité.
Toi donc
qui enseigne les autres,
tu ne t'enseigne pas
toi-même.
Toi qui prêche
de ne pas dérober,
tu dérobes.
Toi qui dis
de ne pas commettre
d'adultère,
tu commets l'adultère.
Toi qui as en abomination
les idoles,
tu commets des sacrilèges.
Toi qui te fais
une gloire de la loi,
tu déshonores Dieu
par la transgression
de la loi,
car le nom de Dieu
est à cause de vous
blasphémé parmi les païens,
comme cela est écrit.
Romains 2,
17 à 24.